there is no reason force for a drug as
simple as insulin which cost 21 dollars
in Canada for a 10 milliliter bottle to
cost the equivalent of a mortgage
payment or sometimes to mortgage
payments I couldn't afford to purchase
my full supply of insulin so my sister
risked her life by sharing hers one
night I took my nighttime dose of
insulin and I left the vial on the
dresser for my sister to see I assumed
that she would think that I had already
taken my dose since I left the vial on
the dresser but she didn't she thought
that I still needed to take my insulin
for the evening so she took less of her
normal dose to ensure that there was
enough left for me to take she put
herself at risk the next day she went
into diabetic ketoacidosis had to be
hospitalized for four days the veins in
her body blew and she had to have a PICC
line in her neck and almost went to a
diabetic coma I couldn't afford my
insulin because Eli Lilly and others
refused to control the cost of insulin
it's it almost cost my sister her life
price gouging is killing people these
pharmaceutical companies are committing
murder and getting away with it